mm all right man it's B and I waited all
weekend that was tough for me you know
how much I love to talk I waited all
weekend to finally review Black Panthers
so I got to imagine everyone who wants
to go right away has seen it so I don't
want to hear any of this [ __ ]
spoilers [ __ ] if you were if you haven't
seen Black Panther I'm gonna give away a
[ __ ] ton of spoilers as I talk about
this spoiler wonderful motion picture I
got back in the day 20 years ago I first
worked with Marvel Comics we did the
daredevil run of comics me and Joe
Quesada and Jimmy Pam yachty under there
Marvel Knights imprimatur their banner
and one of the titles that was also
released there was a Punisher that was
released then as part of the Marvel
Knights but also they did a black
panther run with crispy priests and
Chris priest introduced a lot of
concepts in that book that were really
cool that came to life in this movie the
derma logic came from priests run so
when I went to see the flick man I was
like oh come on like you know I know
Black Panther created by Jack Kirby and
Stan Lee years ago but everyone who
writes the character in comics adds
another spoke to the wheel and I
remember priest runs specifically I
remember like that's a cool idea man
like these all women warriors and stuff
like that to protect the King and they
played with his monarchy as in in
America and that's storyline really cool
so you know years ago man we never
thought we'd see a daredevil movie let
alone a black panther movie and here we
are with the Black Panther movie black
panther a big-screen debut I think most
people assume rightfully is in Captain
America Civil War first mention of
Wakanda maybe in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe is Avengers age of Ultron but
as an old-school movie fan going way
back there has been a black panther
appearance in a major motion picture
once before that's right ladies and
gentlemen in 1989 Spike Lee and do the
right things some of his care
actors carried around all day long and
some of the scenes issue of black
panther comic book and throughout the
movie you would see it and at one point
there's a line that I love and me and
Jason Mewes have repeated to each other
ever since we fell in love with with do
the right thing in 1989 this is the line
they're trying to the kids are trying to
get some pizza out of Sal hurry them up
at the window Sal's the guy who runs the
pizza place and they're talking about
but no they're not talking to Sal this
is talking to somebody else Oh bugging
out who's bugging out I was just like I
want you to boycott Sal's cuz bugging
out is like Boyd's out we're gonna
boycott you fat paw stance and so he's
trying to get the neighborhood to
boycott Sal's and the kids are like man
as good as that pizza there's no way and
at one point one guy holds up the comic
book and he goes black pantry black
panther eat pizza we pizza boy so me and
muse for years have always been like
black panther eat pizza weed pizza it
means like if it's good enough for the
King it's good enough for us so
technically Spike Lee man he was there
early on finger on the pulse put in the
Marvel comic book in a movie Black
Panther and you know again that was
something we never thought we'd see a
Black Panther movie here we are we now
live in an age where the mega everything
for heaven's sakes and thank God they
made this movie instantly this movie
jumps in to the top ten of Marvel films
and their ten-year production it's
something really really special easy
gentlemen Ryan Coogler the director they
did Fruitvale station which is wonderful
movie he did Creed which is a magic
trick of a movie movie that made me care
about the rocky universe again man he
rebooted that universe and he just
brought fresh life like crazy to the to
the Marvel Universe with black panther
insanely talented filmmaker so black
panther as we all know just to kill her
business rewrote the history books and
whatnot we were to talk about it but of
course as everything in this life this
is that sponsored this is from the good
folks I gotta get to Burt kill two birds
with one stone I have to go to the
airport soon so this is for the Dollar
Shave Club ladies and gentlemen if you
join their [ __ ] shower and shave trial
kit man's only like font what is it five
bucks if you go to Dollar Shave Club
dollarshaveclub.com slash
pac-man you get this entire kit of stuff
to shave look at this even comes with a
swipes in there but what I'm gonna do is
before I get gone I'm gonna use this
moment to shave look at this know if
this weird you out don't don't watch but
I'm not gonna use cream or nothin like
that and pray it's not gonna bleed I do
this all the time especially with Dollar
Shave products like that fine handle
sweet but if this would be the one time
where I look and I start bleeding on
camera let's check out mm-hmm so far so
good now I understand the the genius of
all those shows where people watch
people who might get hurt at something
there's a thrill I'm sure the audience
like I hope most of them are like oh
he's okay I'm sure some people like if
he cuts himself that would be
interesting here we go
don't tell me I missed a spy you [ __ ]
me up there you go look at that I get
thinking no better ad for the Dollar
Shave Club than that look at that smooth
well you know I'm mrs. Barwick tube
whatever man for Internet shaven that's
pretty damn good go to dollish
dollarshaveclub.com slash fat man all
one word and chase me Mahalo and jump in
right now for the trial kit it is
fantastic I mean they include ass wipes
which is amazing plus stuff to put on
your face as well the [ __ ] shower and
shave kit okay back to the review man
here's here's the thing that affected me
two things that affected me the most in
this movie maybe it's because I'm a 47
year old man but two moments of fathers
with children I've not fathers of the
sons particularly I don't have a son
I've never had of something I got a
great daughter and stuff but these I had
a dad and so these scenes profoundly
affected
when T'Challa takes the herb takes the
root and lays down in the sand they
cover him up and then he goes to like
the spirit plane or you know to where
that everyone is represented as a
panther and he sees his dad comes down
from the tree and talks to him really
wonderful scene and what a wonderful
notion that we could see our loved ones
someplace afterwards they should market
that so I like that scene very powerful
stuff particularly because you know the
character of takaka is dad who's played
by I won't get everyone's name right
John Canty can i I did a wonderful job
in in civil war although I will say when
they did 1992 to chauka like he looked
you look tidy looked in great shape and
you'd young is I guess it's what I'm
getting at and then what twenty year
twenty fifty years is that twenty
listening twenty nineteen Twenty twenty
five years later or something like that
he aged let that be a lesson to black
man to forget nobody stays Yun favorite
but I love that notion of seeing Chaka
in action as a black panther in Oakland
here's one of the most magical images
you'll see in a movie all year a
spaceship over Oakland like that's
nobody thought to do that what a great
idea it tells an incredible story and
we've got moments in this movie where
you have people looking up at spaceships
young african-american kids in their
neighborhood going like I've never seen
this before that and it works in the
movie and it works on a whole other
different level as well so there's
profound moments like that anyway chakra
comes back to visit his his brother and
I don't know how to pronounce his
brother's name but he's played by
sterling brother sterling Capra and he
you know at first it's it's it's a
bonding like the guy who's with the
shark his brother in the Joe who I think
is he was like looks to the peephole and
he's just like there's some some Grace
Jones looking women outside bald Grace
Jones looking woman who's been to life
and then they it's the it's the
Dermalogica they come in and then the
black panther that appears in the room
and suddenly you realize the guy is a
citizen of Wakanda and they have they're
talking then you realize they're
brothers and it goes deeper than that
and then later on in the movie they
continue to see
see what happened afterwards but in in
that sequence man when you see him black
panther circuit like 1992 and in the 90s
like that like triggered me as I was
sitting there going like wow so Captain
America is the first event of the first
masked superhero in the Marvel Universe
I guess next would be ant-man in the
wasp as we saw in there flashback
adventures now they'll be able to add
Captain Marvel and a young Nick Fury in
the Captain Marvel movie but to chawla
well the black panther - chocolate
technically beats most of the other
costumed Avengers in the Marvel Universe
he predates the Iron Man he predates
Hawkeye Black Widow like it's kind of
cool like how they were able to be like
he's part of the original universe even
before these cats were jumping around in
suits and fighting he he was a guy who
puts on a mask and does the right thing
so but anyway so the scene with with to
challenge Chaka on the spirit plane but
I really loved the scene with Michael B
Jordan who is just such an amazing actor
everyone in this mid cast is fantastic
but Michael B Jordan scene with his dad
when you know they're not I don't don't
know if they're in the same room or not
but he's doing the spirit spirit plane
and and one guys in a room and his dad
is like dead but the his father says no
tears for me because when I was just
gonna choke me up when T'Challa saw his
dad like he was emotional he's like Papa
and he's like loving him and then kill
mongers kill monger sees his dad and his
dad's like no tears me and kill Mara has
like a really kind of like everybody
dies like just straight philosophy
that's gonna take him to the throne one
of the best Marvel villains they've ever
introduced man kill monger go figure
because they gave him a really tragic
backstory he's a kid that was left
behind as we find out later in the movie
ba King to Chaka himself and and Forest
Whitaker's character who is what is it
but but oh my goodness like there's
intrigue here there's layers
Shakespearean layers of family betrayal
and family secrets and stuff like that
but I found that so heartbreaking when
his dad was like no to his dad's looking
at his son like the same we'd seen a
version of see and that's my hat's off
to Ryan Coogler because he set us up
with that scene by being like this is
what a true father and son interact like
and then you see the broken dynamic
between kill monger and his dad and it's
so sad but it gives you like that they
gave him such a great backstory in terms
of he's not just one of these cats like
I'm gonna [ __ ] burn the world because
I'm crazy or I won't want things I mean
wants the throne and he does want to
burn things down but it's not because
he's like I'm evil he looked up he saw a
spaceship he went to find his dad and
his dad was dead with claws in his chest
and like his father had taught him about
what Condon was like someday I want to
bring you back their sons it's they're
beautiful that's gonna make me cry too
like that's that set and then the kid
was left behind so that kid grows up to
be this horrible person that's just like
I'm killing means nothing to me and he's
got this amazing god this guy's ripped
it's crazy how you know you look at
another human being like that's possible
cuz look at this [ __ ] no not here but
man oh man he's got like a body fold
like mr. zas from DC Comics like marks
everywhere for all it kills yet I
thought that was dub so his he's almost
he's you know he's wrong to do what he
does and stuff and his father was wrong
to his father wrongful conduct he gave
ulysses klaw the coordinates or whatever
so ulysses call could bust in and steal
the vibranium [ __ ] so he's not an
innocent man but i stretch the
imagination but like like that kid could
have been saved and i think like that's
why when you get to the end spoilers and
T'Challa is like this is gonna be the
first book on an Outreach Center that's
just good writing man like my hat's off
like he saw an error in the system he's
like kill mugger wouldn't happen we
wouldn't have had that whole adventure
if somebody would have just brought that
kid back to Wakanda instead of leaving
him there killing his dad and leaving
them there and stuff that those are
those are deep themes man then generally
not associated with a comic book movie
wonderfully at old chadwick boseman was
great but we knew he was great we saw
him in captain
civil was civil Captain America 3 Civil
War whatever the [ __ ]
but and Michael B Jordan was fantastic
kill monger but oh my god the the find
of the movie man is lateesha right her
princess sunni was was everything a
Disney Princess I will point out because
Disney owns Marvel and in the comics she
does become Black Panther at one point I
will watch her do anything my god she's
Charm City she was wonderful in the
movie all of her scenes was great they
made her his cue is tech genius if he
will from the James Bond universe that
the whole movie like the whole opening
felt like more like a James Bond movie
then a comic-book movie like
international intrigue not just like
costume two ropes even though there was
some of that as well and a lot of that
but it found ways just like most modern
marvel movies do these days they homage
or or take flavors of other movies so
it's not just straight up a superhero
movie and this one felt like it like
James Bond for the whole opening
sequence and one that latisha writes
Surrey was fantastic Charm City all
throughout let's just go through the
cast real quick Lapita Nyong'o as Nakia
was was wonderful as well and what a
great storyline that was I thought that
was really cool oh the whole like you
know we're watching all these trailers
where we're denying or errors like don't
freeze and Chavo goes I'd never freeze
and then you've realized in the movie
they're talking about
he might freeze on the mission because
his ex-girlfriend's going with him
adorable oh god damn it
Marvel knows how to make movies Ben
Forest Whitaker great as always let's
see
Daniel Kalia to get the fellows and get
out
he plays Maccabi I like that storyline -
I thought that was really cool cuz he
was all pissed that he's like my people
my parents got killed when Klaw attacked
Wakanda and and so I want justice bring
back claw Black Panther doesn't bring
back claw after a stunning sequence in
Korea's that where was South Korea North
Korea South Korea where you see you know
isn't all the trailers with the car that
he's on top of that that is being
virtually driven by Missouri and then
the Ulysses Clause like let's have some
fantastic sequence but he comes back and
he doesn't have the promise like I'm
gonna bring him Claude dead or alive and
he doesn't bring him back and so that
creates this small hole for Michael B
Jordans
kill monger to return to Wakanda with
his tattoo on his lip and and get in
because he does the thing that the Black
Panther doesn't do and you know at the
beginning we see that how important the
Black Panther is to Wakanda the
backstory of Wakanda is [ __ ]
beautifully told and graphically told as
well and anybody who doesn't know any of
the backstory by the end of the movie
you're being [ __ ] five minutes in the
movie or like I'm caught the [ __ ] up
this is excellent storytelling so when
when the flick begins we learn all about
vibranium how robbed there and how the
tribe split and how they all live in
unity and stuff and I'm important the
Black Panthers and so chadwick boseman
x' Black Panther comes home to Chawla
after the adventures presumably in in
you know of Civil War and so he has to
be crowned king and there's a ceremony
eautiful cliffside ceremony and stuff of
bomb waterfalls where you know anybody
could challenge him and only one person
does and who is [ __ ] dope Winston Duke
who plays I think is Mubarak in in the
comics I think he used to be many people
wore the big white suit and stuff big
white gorilla suits but he comes down
he's like you know Jabari we're gonna
challenge and and so it sets it up you
know I'm [ __ ] I do this for a living
and I'm still like blown away when
people do very simple [ __ ] like they
showed us the third act in the first
deck they're like this guy's gonna
challenge for the throne and Black
Panthers gonna win and we're gonna show
you like he takes to the Erb and fights
as the you know Black Panther and does
it without the armor and stuff and then
in the third act you know shoot ain't
even the third day well yeah technically
it's the beginning and third act and
also the end of the third act they have
the whole fight sequence again but this
time of kill monger so you know the
rules and so like at one point when it
looks like kill monger wins and he wins
the Kingdom of Wakanda wins the throne
and his start he's like let's take all
the vibranium mountains of the world
that's the other thing the villains plan
is like let's share this I mean yeah he
wants to enrich himself too but he's
like let's share this with the world why
have we kept people down like for years
our people better press
you had this vibe Raymond did nothing
with it so it's not even like I just
want to burn it all down and like at
this score of it there's like yeah well
I haven't have why hasn't this been
shared blah blah blah so you know it's
not like he just completely dismiss
although with a name like kill monger
you better be better of a textured
villain and they did they created a very
textured though so when kill monger beat
Simon you're like oh [ __ ] what's gonna
happen of course you know spoilers its
Joss not dead he's been found by the
water by the Jabari and they're you know
mending it backs out he's packed in the
snow and so they he when he comes back
he still gets to fighting it's within
the rules of that conflict because the
challenge because he did not submit as
we saw the other guys submit I tell you
good riding like that makes me happy
makes me I'm getting it well up because
I'm like [ __ ] that's good man
I won't ever connect dots as well as
that this is so well done
so it's is this beautiful movie that is
unlike any other Marvel flick that we've
seen thus far it's a wholly realized
universe and we've done God to fully
realize universes before when we went to
Asgard and Thor but like we spent a
little time there we spent a majority of
our time in Wakanda and it is wonderful
and you don't want to leave Angela
Bassett is great and for old fans of
comic book movies that never happen she
was the one we all who wanted a storm
long before there was an x-men movie you
know wound up being Halle Berry but like
it was great to see Angela Bassett
playing between Andy Serkis has a
[ __ ] blast in this movie man like god
bless him uh I'm not a big rings guy but
I appreciate what the dude brought to
that franchise and what now I appreciate
you know the motion capture act except
playing the movies are wonderful plan of
the apes movies are wonderful but like
him just acting and having a blast like
I got a mixtape liking and working that
accent and like hanging outside of car
and blowing [ __ ] away and then spoilers
they [ __ ] take him out like like
early where it like you know but it
makes sense for the plot wonderful stuff
Martin Freeman's fun in it denied
Guerard who we all know from from
Walking Dead is is fantastic is Ocoee
you gotta give me a chance I don't know
some of these names but as the general
of the door of Allah
lots of screen time for her and man she
earns it and and like that fight
sequence her when she climbs on top of
the car and she [ __ ] it throws the
spirit it's [ __ ] phenomenal there's
some spellbinding action sequences here
I've seen some people online go after
the movie like Laurel you can't
understand the fighting it's too close
III understood everything that was going
on wasn't like a Transformers movie to
me where I was like who's beating up who
everything was very clear in this movie
I loved it to death man I don't want to
leave anybody out who I thought was
fantastic I think I hit everybody but
let's talk about like some of the cool
ass sequences the Guria sequence of
course which we've seen a lot of in the
trailers is pitch perfect action and
imagination such imagination on display
you know the themes of he talks to his
dad and his dad just like I you know you
are a good man
it was hard for a good man to be king
I'm you know that's that's true for for
I guess yeah it's tough to lead if
you're not like it's now with that you
know the story when his father says it
to him you're like wow really and then
you see the backstory and you're like oh
it was tough for him he killed his own
brother epic epic stuff
let's see man I've seen it once somebody
said I seen three times I'm going off
the memory of having seen it once this
won't be as long as the last Jedi review
because I saw that like three times
before I finally spoke about or maybe at
least twice but this I want to see once
I saw I saw it on Friday at like 3:00 in
the afternoon I went with my wife Jen
and during the movie man like I looked
over and she was welling up she was
tearing in the flick and it was because
of the portrayal of women in the flick
as well it's in this movie there is some
something for everybody and for a lot of
people some stuff they've never been
shown or given before so you know
afterwards I was like when we were
driving home I was like could you
imagine if you're being like you're a
young african-american kid and like you
walk into the theater and you see the
shot of a young african-american kid
looking up at a spaceship and stuff like
that and you know I was like
representation finally and feeling
that's for me and she was like you don't
even have to be a young african-american
boy she's like I saw things in that
movie that I never saw before that were
based on my gender like you know we
should pointed out she's like the women
beat all the important men in the in the
battle with the exception of course is a
black panther and kill monger going on
and stuff so you know when you read
about people talking about what an
incredible leap forward this movie is it
is one of the most inclusive most
expensive inclusive movies ever made and
it's then forget everything else man
forget like the African American funeral
elebrate sit or women celebrated it's
just a damn good movie doesn't matter I
don't care who you are what country
you're from or the race creed or color a
good movie is a [ __ ] good movie and
this is a great [ __ ] movie man well
thought out well plotted the the good
news is this we know there's Wakanda
going on in vengers because we've seen
it in the trailer so we're gonna get to
go back sooner than we think bad news is
when the [ __ ] are they gonna make
another Black Panther movie I don't
nobody wants to Ryan Coogler I wanna
hear that it's like I just got finished
with this one but you can't give us a
sumptuous meal that good and then you
know how do you keep us down in the
front once we've seen Perry more and
more Black Panther movies from this
point forward I want to go there I want
to go to Wakanda over and over again
what Conda forever as they yelled at my
in my screening before the move again we
were in the theater at the ArcLight and
they introduced the movie and when the
fellow walked away go and enjoy the
picture there's people yelling at well
Conda forever
that's awesome when you can have a movie
gone experience where the whole audience
is in on it and they're all excited
that's why I made like crazy amount of
money this movie's made the most money
of any movie in Marvel history with the
exception of the Avengers I guess at
this point and it had like the biggest
opening of any movie with the exception
of the last Jedi if I read that
correctly so good lord man like if you
haven't seen it rush out and see it I
can't wait to see it again this week I
might actually go tonight may bring
Jason Mewes with me man because I know
he's gonna love it and then together
we'll sit there
hopefully pizza and say Black Panther
eat pizza we eat pizza clink our pizzas
and think about spike please do the
right thing and then enjoy ryan coogler
'he's the black panther [ __ ] i love this
movie a lot I mean I'm just I said it on
a Hollywood babble-on podcast which we
just recorded
me and Ralph Garman and put up this
weekend also at SModcast calm that it
was I forget what I was gonna say but it
was a god it was a signing point and I
just stoned it out of my head I don't
know I don't know what it was what I was
gonna say but but man
I loved it clearly oh here was I was
gonna go off Black Panther for a second
just blow Marvel and I don't do that
because you know I want a job like those
movie I looked at that movie he never
once was there like I'd like to do that
I don't look at hard movies and go I
want to do that I look at those movies
go I want to see that long before I was
a movie maker I was just a movie fan I
just liked movies a lot and and when I
go see a Marvel movie or a well made
comic book flick and generally speaking
that's usually a Marvel movie or a Star
Wars movie or even Creed man when preed
was like oh [ __ ] this dies in my
childhood that makes me feel young again
at age 47 if you can have if you could
bring me into the movies and give me an
experience where I feel like a child
again where I feel like and I'm not
trying to infantilized myself but this
is escapism we pay the money to feel
good I want to go in and be taken back
to a time when movies you know I make
movies so I don't want to go in there
and be like I know how to do that I
don't do that and I did that I'm gonna
go and be transported I want to go to
another world I want to see things that
I've never dreamed of I want to see
things I can't do myself and things I
can't make myself so when I blood blow
these movies ain't trying to get no job
I'm just happy like they legit make me
happy the way my grandmother loved The
Young and the Restless and that made her
happy these are my stories these Marvel
flicks there's ongoing story they've
been telling for ten years in the movies
it's like a second gap but a second grab
it at a happy childhood I enjoyed a lot
of these stories when I was a kid in
comic book form and cartoon form and now
we get to see them on the big screen so
my hat goes off to of course everyone
who worked on Black Panther especially
Ryan
you can tell this movie is a vision one
person's vision I mean you know Marvel
of course does a lot of things by by
committee and whatnot but I feel like
this movie had more of a voice than most
Marvel films and so I take my hat off
and that's not to put other Marvel films
down again I [ __ ] love these movies
but I feel like Kevin Feige was like go
crazy and that's why I'm gonna take this
side beat to just blow up Kevin Feige
for 10 years this dude's been telling a
long story in the Marvel Universe man
and like I love that story that he's
telling and I love how textures and gets
and layered it gets and he brings in
insanely talented filmmakers says hey go
tell your story like you did with with
black panther leighton ryan coogler or
the the guardians movies with james gunn
or ty iki YTD with with Thor Ragnarok
like this is this
this all started 10 years ago the Iron
Man and this is a guy who's like let's
do this let's do this maybe we could do
this and saw it early on we could sell
this whole giant story that takes us all
the way up to Thanos and then what will
happen and now we know like after Thanos
Marvel Universe is gonna be just fine I
mean the things are gonna change it
sounds like heroes are gonna die but we
got brand new heroes man like you know
why I mean I know he's sorted a suit he
winds up as black panther in the comics
but there's no reason why she couldn't
wind up as I mean Mark Barnard would
text him after I saw the movie mark
barnard and said I came and take credit
for the idea he goes why couldn't she be
Iron Man afterwards I'm like oh my god
you're right she's a tech genius and
stuff is RiRi in the comics - the girl's
name is but could be surely it's sky's
the limit at this point so Marvel did it
again man [ __ ] god damn it like be happy
you're alive in this time to watch
people as good as they are do something
like that over and over again it's
wonderful watching people who are
excellent at their jobs come together
and do an excellent job and we get to
benefit from it man we like going to the
movies they're giving us great movies
we're not sitting there going well they
kind of look like the characters I know
they're literally giving you an epic
movie that looks like what you know
smells like what you know and then it's
like nothing you've ever seen before
again you'll see no more endearing
magical image in a movie theater
this year then a little boy in Oakland
looking up at a spaceship who nobody
ever thinks hey man what if somebody in
Oakland saw spaceship like even some
simple as as beautiful I did so I loved
the black man up there obviously I'm
gonna go see it again won't take Jason
Mewes don't forget [ __ ] shower shave get
five bucks dollar shave comm slash fat
man one word and that's it man if you
want to see me live I'm doing some shows
this weekend fat man Batman live in Los
Angeles at the scum and villainy Cantina
on Saturday in the afternoon for
Hollywood babble-on
at the Melrose at the Hollywood improv
on Melrose on Friday night at 10:30
thanks for hanging out man and Thank You
marvel and thank you Ryan Coogler and
thank you the entire cast of the Black
Panther what a [ __ ] to light that was
my wife don't go to the movies with me a
lot anymore man but she actually wanted
to see that shut her cliffs you know
that looks good and she loved it loved
it that's high praise me look I love
everything my wife loved it that's high
praise she don't go from any superhero
movies this one she went for in a big
bad way so you'll love it go see it man
there it is thanks for hanging out what
kind of forever